with the release of the new DLC
Gathering Storm civilization 6 boasts
arguably the most comprehensive
implementation of climate change in a
mainstream video game while climate
change has been featured in many titles
in the past this is mostly as either a
plot point or as a setting and it's rare
for it to be used as a game mechanic
which is why I wanted to look in detail
at how civilization implements climate
change how it affects the gameplay and
assessing how accurate its
implementation is I've been playing
games in the civilization franchise
since about 2003 when it picked up Civ 3
and I've played every PC game and every
expansion with the exception of Civ for
beyond the sword though the game which
I've played the least of is Civ 6
because that came out right in the
middle of when I was doing my PhD in
atmospheric science so it's kind of
fitting that the DLC coming out about
climate change is what's drawing me back
into the game for the record thank you
very much to Kate for sourcing me out
with a press code for the expansion via
the yogscast - I did a livestream width
which is gonna be broken up into lots of
parts if you'd like to watch my terrible
miss plays I've really enjoyed playing
the DLC and I can see myself sinking
dozens and dozens of hours into the game
from here so thanks for running my
productivity 2k for those of you who
might not be aware of how stiff works in
the game you take a civilization from
the Year 4000 BC and you can take it
right the way up to well past the year
2000 AD the game consists of building
and improving cities training military
and non-military units using the terrain
to your advantage building wonders and
then winning by a number of victory
conditions you can wipe out your
opponents with warfare you can overwhelm
them with culture or now you can
actually win diplomatic Lee as well
Gathering Storm introduces an impressive
amount of new content but the most
relevant to us in this video is the way
that it implements natural disasters and
climate change so briefly how does it
work extreme weather events now happen
in the game world
these include storms River floods
droughts and volcanic activity some have
only negative consequences while others
have negative and positive aspects these
disasters will happen regardless of what
the player or players do in the game the
more interesting aspect as far as I'm
concerned is how the game handles
climate change the game now split
strategic resources into material and
power material is things like iron and
horses while power is coal oil and
uranium as well as being able to build a
factory in your industrial zones you can
now also build power plants and if your
city is powered then various parts of
the city become more effective
generating more production for example
burning these fuels however contribute
to the co2 levels in the atmosphere and
increases in the co2 level of the
atmosphere can lead to a variety of
outcomes the game neatly represents this
on this screen where you can see the co2
levels the contribution that my
civilization in this case Sweden has
made to them the increase in global
temperature so naught points 7 degrees
Celsius since the ancient era the
percentage of polar ice lost and the sea
level increase so already we're seeing a
multi-faceted implementation of climate
change which is really cool on this
other screen you can also see which
civilizations have contributed the most
as carbon dioxide to the atmosphere and
also which fuels have been responsible
for the most emissions in this
particular games case I because I
industrialized first have contributed
most of the carbon dioxide and most of
that has been through coal I recently
implemented oil power plants and started
building things like battleships which
burn oil rather than coal and so this
contribution has only recently been
added
ok so first impressions of the system is
that this is a really good
implementation of how human activities
force the world's climate and it's
actually got quite a few subtleties
which are quite satisfying
for example note that it's the total
amount of carbon dioxide that's been
added to the atmosphere that actually
forces the climate rather than worrying
about a particular co2 concentration
it's the total amount of carbon that's
been emitted which is the key fact
what's also cool is that the effects of
those emissions are lagged there are
various stages to climate change going
from phase one with just half a meter of
sea level rise and going all the way up
to phase seven which in the first game I
played we actually hit by the year 1918
week we'd really messed up the world
that lag is something that we see in the
real world between emissions and effects
in the real world case that is
largely because of the fact that the
oceans are absorbing an awful lot of the
carbon resulting in ocean acidification
and an awful lot of the heat resulting
in much warmer oceans obviously the
climate change being felt in discrete
quantized chunks isn't realistic but
this is a game based on tiles so it kind
of has to be done increases in global
temperature as a result of changes in
co2 levels are mostly felt through
changes in the polar ice coverage and
changes in the sea level when settling a
city you are shown where is low-lying
land and you can make changes
accordingly depending on where you want
to build cities and districts in the
first game I played this was absolutely
devastating because we really churned
through all of the stages of climate
change because everybody industrialized
very quickly that meant that people were
lost wanders they built they lost down
districts they built they don't think
anybody actually lost a city but in
theory it is possible to just lose a
city completely the level to stuff has
been flooded now I think the most
impressive aspect of how Gathering Storm
influenced this is through the extreme
event system which is why I brought it
up in the first place on this screen you
can see that there is a chance of a
particular event happening now that is
largely determined by the frequency that
you set at the start of the game you can
make there be lots of disasters or not
very many disasters but underneath you
can see that in the case of storms
there's actually been an increased
chance of storms happening because of
increases in the co2 level in the
atmosphere this is an aspect of climate
change that doesn't get represented very
often it's actually one of the most
worrying aspects increased frequency of
extreme weather events such as
hurricanes floods sandstorms even
extreme outbreaks of cold air can be
directly attributed to increases in co2
concentrations so as well as flooding
and submerging tiles close to the coast
the game punishes you for emitting
carbon dioxide by giving you more of
these extreme events arguably though
where the game really shines is how all
of these changes will affect the
gameplay because arguably the scariest
thing about a changing climate is
changes in human and behavior that it
will cause if this river around my city
which I can't pronounce floods over and
over and over again
destroying my districts and farms I'm
more likely to say stuff this and going
conquer for example Cairo in an attempt
to get further resources without having
to worry about them being destroyed
although mitad Lee there is this volcano
here volcanoes are devastating in this
what made you think this was a good
place to settle your capital I sleep I
don't know changes in sea ice with it
retreating will result in new pathways
being open at the top and bottom of the
map potentially leaving new resources
open for exploitation such as oil but
also new routes for invasion in general
we anticipate there's going to be more
human migration and more conflict in a
world feeling the effects of
anthropogenic climate change and that's
something which seems to be represented
in Gathering Storm that's not even
something that was programmed into the
game it's just something that happens as
a result of human behavior which i think
is really cool another interesting point
is that the game effectively forces you
to use fossil fuels
if you don't utilize power in your
economy then you're at a massive
production disadvantage and early in the
game the only way to get power is
through coal or through oil both of
which emit a lot of carbon though coal
comes first and emits the most then oil
comes a little bit later on and emits
slightly less carbon it's only with the
advent of more modern technologies that
you can build geothermal plants nuclear
power plants and hydroelectric dams so
in a sense the game views anthropogenic
climate change as an inevitable
consequence of human civilization again
it's an interesting consequence of the
game not so much in the mechanic itself
but in its implications for the matter
if you like so on the whole Gathering
Storm I think there's a really good job
of representing what anthropogenic
climate change will look like of course
it doesn't get everything right for
example you would expect to see a
certain amount of natural variability
over the six thousand years of the games
run time though because of the nature of
the game and the fact that it's based on
tiles I can see why they didn't
implement this also I'm sure some people
will take exception to the fact that the
game builds nuclear power as being
almost completely carbon neutral the
status of how carbon neutral nuclear is
is kind of up for debate and it depends
on how you define it but
for the purposes of the game again I can
see why they did this also as I
mentioned earlier the game breaks down
climate change into these discrete
levels from level one to level seven by
the time you reach level seven the sea
level will have risen three and a half
meters eighty-five percent of the polar
ice will have gone but there's no real
reason why it would just stop then in
the first game I played we should have
seen much much worse starting to happen
at that point the game could start
introducing things like desertification
large areas of land becoming arid
further sea level rise although the game
then runs a risk of basically becoming a
map of worms where the water level just
keeps rising and rising until presumably
the Inca are left but this is one area
that I feel like the game could have
expanded on perhaps they just didn't
think that anybody would get to climate
change level 7 but in my first game we
demonstrated that it was very possible
overall though I think the DLC does a
fantastic job and it's a really great
way of getting this information out
there to the general public it's a
pretty faithful version of what an earth
with an arbitrary level of co2 emitted
by human civilization will look like I
think it's interesting though that all
this information is available to the
players in the game from the very
beginning when you've settled your first
city you can actually decide to move it
away from the coast if you're in danger
of your capital city being flooded as a
result of climate change happening five
or six thousand years in the future I
would argue that that's an unrealistic
part of the adaptation but of course
this is how games work you have to know
how to be able to play them perhaps if
we'd known the radiative effects of
burning fuels to further our economies
from the beginning we wouldn't be in the
situation that we're in now and I can't
help but wonder if the real-life
industrial age areas had access to their
very own civil appear what they have
made the same decisions that they made
thanks again to 2k for providing access
to the game I've really really enjoyed
playing it the DLC adds a huge amount
SIF feels really challenging again now
and I can't wait to play more after this
video is out I hope you enjoyed the
video do give it a like if you did and
if you enjoyed it do let me know in the
comments because I've not done anything
like this on my channel before and
possibly I could do more on the
interplay
of science and videogames to be honest
any excuse to just play some more thanks
again I'll see you in the next one